thank you
whenever I can walk out of low library
and not be let out in handcuffs it's a
good take it is quite an honor to be
here with you class of 2010 with your
Dean's and professors so many of New
York's finest so I got to know well
while I was here at college as you step
out of here today you will define your
legacy and that of our country these are
days when we each are called to be clear
about what we want not just from our
lives but for this world these are days
of Dickensian contradiction walk into
the department of justice and you will
be greeted by photos of two men both
graduates of this College beneath their
names you will see the words President
and Attorney General
a few weeks ago if you walked into a
field
Northy here in upstate New York you
would have seen pictures of these same
two men held above the heads of angry
protesters with words scrolled beneath
their pictures saying Lynch Eric Holder
Lynch President Obama these men these
women fantasize about taking us back to
the 18th century and they distort what
our founding fathers and mothers hoped
for all of us let's party like it's 1776
says Sarah Palin as if the 18th century
was good for any of us
I mean sure rich white man could vote
but their life expectancy was about 38
and in the wake
that she and others leave as they
crisscross across this country the
Governor of Arizona has just penned a
law that greatly empowers the ability of
your local police department in Phoenix
or Tucson to put you in jail if you
don't have your papers on you and they
think you look or you sound like you
might be for it I will leave here this
afternoon and walk over to a press
conference we will announce that we're
filing a lawsuit with the ACLU to
invalidate that law
and this Wednesday I'll be in Texas were
former Secretary of Education Rodney
Page and I will be taking on the
governor and his school board who want
to change the way that the children
across the South are taught to minimize
what they learned about Thomas Jefferson
to minimize the very work use of the
word democracy to maximize the portrayal
of the Confederacy and to defend Senator
Joe McCarthy I say to you class of 2010
let's party like his 2010 let's party
like ours is the nation that brought the
world the 21st century and yours is the
generation that will define it and now
is the time for you to declare that we
will move this country ever forward and
never backward because now is the time
for all of us who believe in the
greatness of this country to stand up
now is the time for all of us who would
rather build this country up and out of
this recession than tear it apart and
leave it in it now is the time for all
of us who believe in hope not hate to
speak up and be heard because change is
what happens each and every day not just
what happens on Election Day if you've
learned anything while at this College
in this city you have learned how to
listen to people who do not look like
you do not sound like you did not grow
up where you grew up this is the most
valuable thing you can carry out into
this world the first time I left this
campus it was involuntarily
and blessed with some refunded financial
aid dollars with loans bought a jeep and
I headed down to Mississippi where the
governor was seeking to shut down a
historically black University and turn
it into a prison sort of like the school
to Prison Pipeline no pipeline school
the prison the we showed up just after
Byron de la Beckwith had been put in
prison thirty years too late for having
killed n-double a-c-p leader Medgar
Evers and we announced that we would
have a big protest to show the world at
Mississippi that Mississippians did not
believe in turning colleges into prisons
the Klan put out a press release I kid
you not they apparently have a press
secretary the Klan put out a press
release saying that they would kill one
or all the four leaders of the protest
and I was one of those and we decided
that it was important that this protest
not just have black Mississippians and
it also have white Mississippians
because you can walk around to hear
murmurs and know that there were lots of
people who disagreed with the governor's
plan but given the charge to find white
liberals in Mississippi in 1994 we
figured Earth's day was the best place
to look for him
and so we sent out teams of student
organizers to all of the historically
white campuses and sadly Mississippi
that's the history you only have
historically white colleges and
historically black colleges and by six
o'clock all of them had checked in
except for one and by midnight I fell
asleep at my desk I know you all can't
recall this but there was a day before
cell phones I fell asleep at my desk
waiting for them to call in and at 2:00
a.m. the phone rang and they said then
we're okay but we had a bad situation of
its state Mississippi State we need you
to get down to the Waffle House right
away
well like any you know college jock you
couldn't keep me away from Waffle House
so I hopped in my car and I ran down
there we huddled around the table they
explained that the students wouldn't let
them speak til the end did they meant
the very end after it turned into a keg
party in the third encore Sweet Home
Alabama it's a great song
they were led up to speak and they
chanted save the black colleges and the
crowd roared back get a rope and here in
the Pawnee woods in Mississippi north of
Philadelphia where New Yorkers Chaney
and Goodman sorry uh Gunnar Goodman and
Schwerner and Mississippian Chaney were
ordered to their death by the local
sheriff they ran to their cars and they
did that little Mississippi two-step
where you drive just fast enough to get
the heck out of town and just slow
enough that the sheriff won't notice you
and we were huddled around this table in
this Waffle House and there was a man
staring at it's an old white man who had
gold rings on every finger and a baggy
shirt in a state where for a hundred
bucks and no felonies you can carry a
firearm wherever you want to go and he
kept staring at us real hard and we
noticed in that instant that his shirt
was baggy and a hunk below his pant line
and we were the only black folks in the
restaurant and it was 3 a.m. at this
point been there debating and discussing
and he walked over to our table carrying
two large bags and he looked at us real
intently and said are you all the boys
I've been seeing on television now is
from California by way of New York and
one guy was from st. Louis another was
from New Orleans and a third one was
from Chicago the four of us in other
words were not accustomed to anybody
calling us boy who wasn't our boy and
let alone some old dude at 3 o'clock in
the morning looked like he might want to
kill us but we were the only black folks
in the restaurant the Klan to put out a
press release and we so we just looked
at him we said
yes sir he said hold on a second and he
turned around to put down his to-go
order and his dominant hand was hidden
and two of the other organizers were
football players and they were getting
ready to jump him because they were
convinced that he was going to swing
around and shoot us and I said hold up
let's just listen to what he has to say
and they gave me this look like then we
might be dead by the time he says it and
I said just hold up hear what he has to
say and he spun around and he extended
his hand he said well I just want to
shake your hand because if I'd been born
a n-word in this crazy state I'd be mad
as heck - I own the used car lot
right down Highway 49 explain the gold
rings
if you need anything if you need to
money if you need a car you just come
and see me and know that I'm always on
your side so the next morning I sent the
organizers down there to get 100 bucks
for him because I was getting paid 85
bucks a week and I needed to get paid
and they needed their faith in humanity
restored because the day before we had
made a critical mistake we had assumed
that we knew who our allies were and we
assumed that we knew who our Abba who
our ally certainly wasn't and won got us
a death threat to our face from a angry
crowd and the other got us an open hand
from a man who we assumed to give us
nothing but grief that is the courage
that going to school in New York City
teaches you that is the gift that you
bring from here out into the world in
these times when we see the graduates of
this College as heroes and angry mobs
see them as boys to be lynched let us
all be clear that we are the change this
country needs you are the ones who will
make sure that it happens and most
importantly when faced with that moment
of choice always go with your gut it
always pays off in the very end thank
you and God bless